all righty it's that time for drew's
news and with me at the desk is my
trusty co-pilot and my love rock
hi
hi everybody and happy holidays hi
hi
um rossi i'm excited because you've got
a story for us i do first up we've got a
sparkly hairstyle that's perfect for the
holiday season take a look at this day's
reports tick tock is covered in fairy
hair
yeah it's a glittery hair trend where
people have actually they weave tinsel
into their hair to make it look sparkly
which is so cute and celebrities are all
over it here's casey musgraves showing
off her shimmer don't you want to look
like that right and fairy hair is
everywhere on tick tock with over 90
million views wow um i will seriously i
would rock this so hardcore but i want
it like in a rat tail just like that
you know it's like back here so i can
just i do love a rat tail maybe we can
bring those back too i'm into this uh
tinsel hair thing i think so too i think
it's the perfect time of the year to try
this if it's sort of on you're on the
bubble like could i pull this off or not
holidays new years yes tis the season
tinsel the season all right well next up
if you're dating someone new and you
don't know how to tackle the holiday
gift situation with them we've got some
advice
the zo reports
that they talk to dating pros who say
the key is to make it thoughtful
not lavish they say that one ideal gift
is something that you can do together
like a gift certificate for a restaurant
or a cooking class instead of expensive
jewelry invest in that little gag gift
that kind of keeps it light referenced
as a joke rather than i'm dying to marry
you yeah so the headline is
light-hearted thoughtful don't break the
bank and i like this advice you know
ross thought well there it is that
awkward thing when you're first dating
somebody and like you know you say i got
you like um a starbucks gift card and
you got me like a tiffany bracelet i'd
be like oh okay what do we do so there
is that thing it's like where are we in
our relationship are we getting are we
getting each other the really thoughtful
nice thing or are we just sort of still
recording i i think it's actually nice i
was thinking what do you get somebody
what about giving them your favorite
book you know what i mean like something
about you
that gives this is a little insight to
me i like this i like that clap of hands
who would be into that
something
here's a way to get to know me better
i think the question we all want to know
is like what is too much because there
are high stakes when you get someone
especially at the beginning of a
relationship because one person might be
kind of
toes in the water and one person might
be like i am jumping into the deep end
with bricks tried to my feet and i want
in yeah and you're just like a present
can really like tip the scales of too
much
sometimes it's intimidating it can be if
you get somebody something that's too
much it can be it could lead to a
beautiful place but it could also lead
to anybody
yeah
like your favorite book can be like too
much for some people to handle you think
so it's happened to me i know oh did you
did you give the book or did you get the
book i gave the book um i also bought
someone like this really cute little
like plant and they let it die oh and i
was like that's such a metaphor for this
relationship yes but that's also a good
to know if you get someone to plant they
can't handle it they can't handle it
yeah i'm also like if you can't take
care of a little tiny plant then
um
i guess like what would you ideally like
if you were dating someone
and you were developing your feeling
okay i'm there i'm picturing it but
you're
like
what gift would make you go
huh i think i do like this person
not a plant
well i thought a plant was nice
maybe a succulent because you'll really
have to water those you know
so you want something low maintenance
yeah i'm trying to think what welly
wellington got me for our first
christmas um
and it was so special to me so
especially you can't remember what it
was
all right well good news that that love
story worked out so whatever he did at
work
i say
here's one thing like my best friend
literally just texted me and she was
like oh i'm worried to put this thing
out there on like social media should i
say it or not and i said if you're
questioning it do don't do it don't do
it that's good that is my advice if
somewhere in your brain you're getting
little thoughts somewhere in your gut
something's not ringing right listen to
that
go your gut is there for a guide and i
think yes
not just with with this but for
everything everything forgotten you're
uncertain and questioning it listen to
that
and i also say take a risk life is short
and if somebody doesn't like what you
get them the next moving on thank you
for giving me the time to find somebody
better thank you so much
better suited for me and you absolutely
all right up next you know there's so
many uses for tick tock and this holiday
you can even find gift wrapping hacks
how about that i'll take it the new york
post
they're recording tick tock has tips for
how to wrap even the most pain in the
butt gifts like things that are round
why are they so hard to wrap candles
anything in a tube well check out this
hack from lenia she cut slits into
wrapping paper to give you an easy fold
at each end how many times you tried to
wrap something like this
drew i would like to give this a a shot
all right i have to tell you i have
never seen this trick and i am so into
it well can can i just point out what
we're wrapping with by the way okay
first of all how okay okay i'll just
wait
for the paper this is adorable look at
this
this is custom wrapping paper
from a company called uh gift wrap my
face
and i have look there's little rocky
ross ones and we have drew ones too now
does the hack work you've been doing it
does it work i'm doing it right now so
far side one is working you know martha
stewart actually changed my rapping game
she came on the show and taught me about
hospital corners i've never been a
better rapper since really shocker
martha stewart changed my life
um she does know rappers she has a show
with snoop dogg hey
no kidding right
um okay
i gotta tell you this is really working
rossi like this is so good look at this
true perfect
so smart well done linea hi
well lydia thank you for changing my
rapping game literally you and martha
stewart not bad company and i want to
thank gift wrapped my face for this
adorable paper that they made with our
faces on it hence the wrap my face um
but guess what everyone in the audience
today is getting a five roll bundle of
personal gift wrapping from gift wrap my
face
so that you
can put your face
on your holiday wrapping tool
i know i'm keeping this girl for me
thank you i love this
thank you gift wrapping game raise
[Music]